you know what's crazy so this whole
thing with five million dollars yeah
i was on fox and friends and we talked
about it
and we've raised another million dollars
so we're shy of six million dollars you
give a ten you give ten thousand dollars
which was very nice of you but
we're at uh uh uh uh shy of six million
you know what's amazing you know what's
the craziest thing about the story
here's what's the craziest thing about
story one of the guys gave a hundred
thirty seven thousand dollars okay now
this guy who gave 137 thousand dollars
guess where he's based out of i told you
the story yesterday he's a
corporate lawyer
from india
so
in email we ask why are you giving this
137 thousand dollars you don't even live
in america look at his answer he says
you know i'm giving 137 thousand dollars
because when u.s is at peace the rest of
the world does good hell yeah when u.s
isn't at peace we feel it i want to see
whatever i whatever i can do to help
unify u.s the rest of us are going to do
better a corporate attorney from india
gave 137 000